wenn die rechnung auf den tisch kommt
werden alle zur geldbörse greifen müssen
sanktionen gegen staaten gab es noch nie
zum nulltarif das muss den menschen im
westen noch genauer erklärt werden
nachdem die strafmaßnahmen gegen
russland angelaufen sind ob die
russische wirtschaft wirklich in die
knie gezwungen werden kann wenn ein
wichtiges schlupfloch für den handel
offen bleibt ist noch eine ganz andere
frage dies und einiges mehr jetzt in der
phoenix runde putins krieg wie
einschneidend sind sanktionen
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst hier im studio professor karl
stärke ist bei uns sie sind osteuropa
historiker und publizist ebenfalls im
studio ist janis kluge von der
forschungsgruppe ost europa und eurasien
von der stiftung wissenschaft und
politik hier in berlin zugeschaltet sind
martina fischer referentin für frieden
und konfliktbearbeitung bei brot für die
welt und axel mattern ist vorstand von
hafen hamburg marketing
das ist die zentrale anlaufstelle für
alle kunden des hamburger hafens und
auch die partner helfen die sich wie die
perlen an einer schnur an nord und
ostseeküste entlang ziehen herr schlegel
halten sie den funktionen für
erfolgsversprechend werden sie die
russische führung letztendlich doch
beeindrucken
sanktionen muss man einsätze wenn man
keine anderen mittel bereit ist
einzusetzen
das verstehe ich jedenfalls alles leid
aber die sanktionen werden jetzt sie sie
werden jetzt keinen einfluss haben auf
die
entscheidungsschlacht
die stadt findet in der ukraine
sie wird das blutbad dass putin
anrichtet in den städten der ukraine
nicht aufhalten sondern das sind
langfristige
wirkungen aber es wird jetzt unmittelbar
nur abhängen vom widerstand und von der
tafel könnte ukrainer kluge die
sanktionen umfassen ja fast alles außer
öl und gas das hab ich gerade mit dem
schlupfloch gemeint dass da gerade das
noch besteht kann man denn wirklich auf
sanktionen im energie sektor dass bei
das bei weitem größte
exportgut die das wichtigste aus fuhr
gut der russischen föderation verzichten
ja die sanktionen die bisher verhängt
worden sind
sind sehr massiv und ich glaube wir
haben noch nicht gesehen in gänze welche
welche zerstörungskraft sie in der
russischen wirtschaft haben werden ich
bin tatsächlich überzeugt dass die
russische wirtschaft sich komplett
transformieren wird von einer offenen
volkswirtschaft zu einer relativ
geschlossenen dass eine massive
veränderung und gerade jetzt ist das
chaos und ist praktisch die sagen dass
das die pause in handel und
finanztransaktionen ist die so massiv
und so wirkungsvoll dass man zumindest
in den nächsten tagen sagen kann ob
russland jetzt diese eine milliarde mehr
oder weniger pro tag aus dem
energieexport bekommt ist jetzt für die
wirkung der nächste woche nicht
entscheidend mittelfristig längerfristig
ist das aber schon ein wichtiger faktor
fischer wir wollen wir heute vor allen
dingen über sanktionen reden helfenden
eigentliche sanktionen russland wieder
auf den rechten weg zurück zu bringen
also auf den weg des dialogs und der
verständigung sowohl mit der ukraine als
auch mit den anderen anrainerstaaten
auch mit dem westen
also gut für die welt das christliche
hilfswerk führt dass ich hier auch
spreche ist davon überzeugt dass es
keine alternative im moment gibt zu den
sanktionen es ist das einzige zivile
mittel was wir haben und man kann diesen
schrecklichen krieg dieses ganze leiden
und vor allen dingen diese massive
verletzung des völkerrechts und
menschenrechts nicht einfach
stehenlassen also man braucht diesen
sanktionen
aber man muss sich sehr bewusst sein
darüber was die leisten können also wir
sehen natürlich auch mit großer sorge
dass er die menschen abschneiden in
russland das sind ja nicht alle in
russland für diesen krieg das ist ein
gewisses dilemma was wir sehen also man
bräuchte eigentlich auch den austausch
weiter auf dieser ebene von kultur von
jugendaustausch also all diese ganzen
verbindungen wir werden jetzt natürlich
auch geklappt aber wie gesagt es gibt
keine alternative ich denke nur man muss
nicht klar darüber sein dass sanktionen
jetzt nicht diesen konflikt
transformieren können also ist das ist
sogar damit zu rechnen dass weitere
provokationen erfolgen damit muss man
rechnen und darauf muss man sich einfach
auch einstellen um möglich diesen
konflikt zu transformieren braucht etwas
anderes dafür braucht diplomatie und
davon auch sehr viel im moment gut wir
sprechen diesen aspekt auch noch an herr
mattern verbindungen gekappt sagt frau
fischer da ist ja quasi über nacht
kollabieren da ja jahrzehntelang
aufgebaute entwickelte
handelsbeziehungen auch beziehungen
zwischen unternehmen
überfordert dass auch die westliche
wirtschaft in dieser heftigkeit in
dieser schnelligkeit in der das jetzt
vonstatten geht
da wir werden da sicherlich noch einiges
in zukunft sehen also wir haben jetzt
natürlich mit den hamburger hafen
betrachten für
330.000 container die wir nicht mehr
abfertigen
beispielsweise aber wir haben natürlich
auch massengüter und andere waren die
wir mit russland um schlagen im
hamburger hafen und in den häfen an den
an den deutschen küsten und die
kollateralschäden die aus vielen
handelsbeziehungen entstehen die werden
wir erst im nachgang sehen nicht jetzt
in der anfangszeit
also eine mittel und langfristige frage
sowohl was die wirksamkeit angeht als
auch die kollateralschäden der eigenen
wirtschaft jannis gibt es kluge gibt es
eigentlich eine erfolgsgeschichte der
sanktionen wann haben sie denn wirklich
etwas bewirkt ich glaube es wichtig zu
sehen dass sanktionen nie alleine wirken
dh sanktionen sind ein außenpolitisches
instrument das in verbindung mit anderen
instrumenten auch in verbindung mit
diplomatie natürlich eingesetzt wird und
es gibt es gibt erfolgsgeschichten aber
ich muss gleich dazu sagen dass
erfolgsgeschichten von sanktionen immer
interpretation sind das heißt man muss
jeden fall ganz genau an seinem kontext
anschauen und dann kann man zu der
aussage kommen ja da haben sanktionen
geholfen oder haben sie nicht geholfen
allgemein häufig zitierte
erfolgsgeschichten ist ist das ende der
apartheid in südafrika ist
der iran die in 2015 oder auch das match
gab kommen 2014 und 15 das heißt es gibt
diese es gibt diese erfolgsgeschichten
aber es ist da natürlich ganz schwer es
gibt keine methode um felsenfest
festzustellen das war jetzt die
sanktionen
das ist interpretation und deshalb kann
man pauschale aussagen die sanktion
funktionieren nicht oder funktionieren
immer natürlich nicht treffen es ist ein
instrument wie viele andere aus dem
britische instrumente das sehr stark
eben vom kontext abhängig ist ich möchte
aber auch sagen dass diese sanktionen
jetzt verhängt wurden in dieser form
historisch noch nie dagewesen sind das
heißt es gab nie so eine so heftige
sanktionen in so kurzer zeit gegen eine
so vernetzte und große volkswirtschaft
es gibt zwar die gleichen maßnahmen auch
gegen andere volkswirtschaften habe es
ist kein vergleich weil das alles im
zeitraffer innerhalb weniger tage
passiert auch in dieser breite flügel
wir haben ja
2014 auch erlebt dass schon mal
sanktionen gegen russland erlassen
worden sind im zusammenhang mit der
annexion der krim und der unterstützung
der separatisten im sogenannten don was
also in der ost ukraine
wirklich wirksam waren die nicht oder
er geht doch weiter gibt er zieht
einfach sein programm durch
es interessiert ihn auch gar nicht ob es
folgen hat für den lebensstandard
in russland selbst hatte eine diskussion
gegeben ob die stagnation und die
situation jetzt in russland in erster
linie durch die
durch die sanktionen ausgelöst worden
ist oder durch die unfähigkeit des
regimes selbst überhaupt sich neu
aufzustellen
das land zu modernisieren das ist dazu
ist er offensichtlich nicht in der lage
sondern er hat nach zwei jahren nach 20
14 jahr wieder die flucht nach vorn
angetreten
es gab die können dann gab es den doors
und
jetzt jahre später ein angriff auf die
ukraine selbst und wenn man die rede von
heute nachmittag gehört hat das ist ja
nicht ein eingehen auf die
dürfen ist und auf die probleme jetzt
entstehen durch die sanktionen sondern
was er gesagt hat ist die helden die
dort gefallen sind in wahrheit ist hier
die in der ukraine unterwegs sind die
werden wir mit renten ausstatten die
veteranen bekommen ihre arten kein
einziges wort über die situation
der sinkenden lebensstandard oder die
befürchtungen die die bevölkerung
natürlich hat über diesen in ihren augen
vollständig nutzlosen überflüssigen
schädlichen und verrückten krieg den
russen zu erklären was da eigentlich vor
sich geht das hat er ja gar nicht
versucht sondern wiederum die flucht
nach vorn also eine weitere eskalation
frau fischer welche erfahrungen hat ein
brot für die welt mit sanktionen auch in
anderen ländern wir müssen davon
ausgehen dass diese sanktionen die jetzt
erlassen worden sind in erster linie die
russische bevölkerung treffen ganz
bestimmt nicht putin und seine entourage
wie ist das bei anderen sanktionen
gewesen zum beispiel gegen den iran
gegen syrien gegen libyen haben sie da
auch erfahrungswerte was das dann dort
die sanktionen die ja politisch etwas
erzwingen sollen was das dort mit der
mit der bevölkerung macht es
ist nicht unbedingt immer so dass die
bevölkerung wenn sie dann so stark
betroffen ist von sanktionen sich dann
politisiert oder dann gegen gegen das
regime stellt also man muss schon davon
ausgehen dass es auch teilweise
unerwünschte
solidarisierungseffekt gibt also ist es
gibt beides also ich denke mal wir haben
alle immer wenn wir sanktionen im kopf
haben vielleicht dieses beispiel noch so
von südafrika damals apartheidstaat und
das ist glaube ich so ein modell gewesen
wo es wirklich auch gewirkt hat wobei
kommt maßnahmen sanktionen gedrückt
haben also in aller regel
treffen sie natürlich schon die
schwachen in der gesellschaft ich kann
das jetzt für russland nicht beurteilen
ich kenne dieses land nicht gut genug
ich denke nur man muss davon ausgehen
dass man im moment das nicht vorhersagen
kann und was ich wirklich ein wichtiges
argument findet es wurde glaube ich auch
schon angedeutet dass diese sanktionen
mit sicherheit erst mittel- und
langfristige wirkung haben also meine
befürchtung ist dass wir jetzt wirklich
nicht zu einer kurzfristigen
verhaltensänderung führen werden und
deshalb ist es so enorm wichtig in der
jetzigen situation wo putin ja ja auch
immer diese atomstreitkräfte nochmal in
alarmbereitschaft gesetzt hat also diese
eskalationsspirale nicht noch weiter zu
treiben dass putin dann interesse daran
hat ist völlig klar aber man müsse alles
tun denke ich also eine solche
eskalation zu verhindern und auf
diplomatischen wege tatsächlich auf
allen kanälen sozusagen allen
diplomatischen möglichkeiten
versuchen entgegen aber fischer das
passiert ja gerade das passiert ja
gerade heute hat ja man kann noch mal
mit putin telefoniert aber sehr gerade
schon die rede von hat vor davon heute
abend erwähnt worden von wladimir putin
gibt da nicht einen millimeter nach man
kann sich nach dieser rede kaum
vorstellen dass es in absehbarer zeit
diplomatische möglichkeiten einer
konfliktlösung dort gibt
aber da genau da will ich gern ein haken
weil das ist genau der punkt ich denke
es sind zwei sachen wichtig weil dieser
situation wenn man der diplomatie eine
chance geben will dann
muss man von maximalpositionen
abweichen und zwar alle beteiligten also
wenn man von russland tatsächlich
fordert und das fordern wir ja alle
diesen krieg zu beenden und diese truppe
wieder abzuziehen dann wird man
irgendetwas diplomatisch anbieten müssen
und ich glaube das geht auch nur im
rahmen von gipfeltreffen das geht nicht
einfach auf der eben dieses normandie
formats also deutschland frankreich
russland ukraine und es geht auch nicht
einfach nur in verhandlungen zwischen
der russischen und der ukrainischen
regierung es wird irgendwann auch
gipfeltreffen erheben müssen soll dieser
ganze konflikt ist ja eingebettet in den
großen konflikt zwischen russland und
der nato der seit 2000 an spielt und
langsam eskaliert ist und ich glaube es
wird nicht ohne gipfeltreffen auch
abheben die nato endet nun mal nicht in
europa sondern eben auf der anderen
seite des ansage gibt es interessen kann
man sich eintragen der zweite punkt ja
bitte wenn ich noch einen zweiten punkt
anführen fügen darf der sehr wichtig ist
also das eine ist das abrücken von
maximalpositionen das andere ist dass
man sich in der ganzen sprache
versuchen sollte möglichst also ja nicht
mit polemik
zu antworten also auch wenn von putins
seite sehr viel polemik im spiel ist
dass man versucht die sprache da einfach
neutraler zu halten denn sonst ist man
verbrannt also man kann dann nicht mehr
miteinander reden wenn man diese polemik
bedient in der gleichen weise und es
wird diese eskalationsspirale einfach
immer weiter anhaltend hier kommen wir
kommen da sie fast ihr habt gute schöne
lasse gebe ich ihnen jetzt die
möglichkeit gleich darauf zu antworten
es finden unentwegt anstrengungen
stadtbibliothek voranzukommen im
augenblick ist es so dass eine
verhandlungsdelegation sich getroffen
hat gleichzeitig aber wird der kampf um
die 1 schließung bekannt gibst usw
geführt und die
maximalforderung von putin ist ganz klar
er will diese städte nehmen er will sie
die er wird sie dem erdboden gleich
machen und da schlagen sie vor jetzt ein
gipfeltreffen das ist ja völlig jenseits
der wirklichkeit
es wird jetzt entschieden und die ground
jetzt wird entschieden und sie schlagen
vor dass man die rhetorik mäßigen soll
haben sie die rede von putin gehört er
redet von der ukraine als nazis
nationalisten die entmachtet werden
müssen er besetzt ein land und da machen
sie einen vorschlag zu einem
gipfeltreffen
häufig werde nicht nur einen vorschlag
zu einem treffen machen wenn ich da noch
drauf antworten darf ich würde mir sogar
wünschen dass es eine 1 1 team von
mediatoren gibt einen un
sonderbeauftragten irgendwelche menschen
aus ländern die nicht direkt in diesem
konflikt eingebunden sind die sich
bemühen zwischen diesen drei ländern
ukraine russland und usa
beziehungsweise nato also es geht ja am
ende dann um den konflikt mit der nato
dort eine ein kompromiss zu finden und
von maxi dass dann alle beteiligten von
maximalpositionen abweichen müssen
natürlich auch die russische seite ist
vollkommen klar ich sehe keine
alternative
wir können noch nicht tatenlos einfach
in einen atomkrieg steuern
miteinander
kommen jetzt ein bisschen vom thema
sanktionen ab ich werde mir kommen auch
das thema noch einmal zurück heute wenn
es um die rolle china geht sie haben
jetzt auch von vermittlern mediatoren
gesprochen vor wenigen minuten soll der
meldung gekommen sein dass sich der
saudische kronprinz bin salman angeboten
hat als vermittler ob das der richtige
aufgrund seiner biografie ist eine
andere frage ich würde gerne auf den
aspekt der der sanktionen noch mal
zurückkommen herr kluge jetzt haben alle
vier hier im studio gesagt die würden ja
erst mittel- und langfristig wenn
überhaupt
arbeiten dann die sanktion er für die
ukraine oder eher für putin
die sanktionen arbeiten gegen putin die
sanktionen unterminieren das bisherige
herrschaftsmodell von putin das nicht
nur auf repression drohte sondern auch
auf einem relativ komfortablen
lebensstandard für viele russen was ich
sage nochmal ergänzen ich meine richtig
arbeitet die zeit für die ukraine oder
für putin bei den sanktionen auch die
zeit arbeitet gegen putin an der stelle
ich glaube es ist aktuell einfach noch
nicht sichtbar welche auswirkungen diese
sanktionen haben werden ist es jetzt
schon so dass jeden tag mehr fabriken in
russland still stehen die bänder stehen
still beispielsweise beim großen
automobilwerk after war es das sind
40.000 menschen arbeiten und so trifft
es jetzt eine ein werk nach dem anderen
das heißt es wird sehr sehr massive
folgen haben ich glaube dass russland
damit auch nur wird umgehen können wenn
sie eine art von planwirtschaft
einführen zumindest für diese
betroffenen betriebe ein akuter mangel
von allen sozusagen importen die von
denen die busproduktion abhängt eben
auftritt das heißt es aus meiner sicht
entfalten die sanktion ihre wirkung aber
sie haben sie auch schon 11 also erneut
ein stück weit enteilt ist es ist schon
eine sehr drastische wirken jetzt schon
da und es ist auch jetzt schon klar für
jeden in der russischen elite dass putin
das lebenswerk dieser dieser menschen
praktisch zerstört hat das heißt er hat
sich natürlich dadurch viele feinde
gemacht ich sage nicht dass das dazu
führt dass es irgendetwas lösen kann
dass es irgendetwas sozusagen die zwar
konnte der etwas ähnlichem aber es ist
so dass putin mit diesem krieg gegen die
interessen der gesamten zumindest
wirtschaftlichen elite aber auch vieler
teile der zivilen regierung vielleicht
sogar teile des
verteidigungsministeriums man weiß ja
auch das sagen auch viele soldaten gar
nicht wussten wo sie da reingeraten dass
das sozusagen putin aktuell diesen krieg
gegen die russische elite führt und das
ist denke ich ja auch ein ziel der
sanktionen gewesen dass man praktisch
eine zweite front eröffnet und aus
meiner sicht ist sie schon da also wir
müssen ja nur den russischen aktienmarkt
anschauen denen es nicht mehr gibt muss
den rubel kurs anschauen ja also wir
sehen einfach massive auswirkungen auch
jetzt schon deshalb will ich sagen es
gibt die langfristigen wirkungen aber es
gibt auch jetzt schon ganz massive wird
gut wir kommen auf dieser aspekt vor
allem darauf die sogenannten oligarchen
gleich nach zurückkehrten über den
hamburger hafen laufen ja sehr viele
importgüter nach russland die stehen
jetzt zum teil ja auf der sanktionsliste
also heute güter ersatzteile
hochwertige
industriegüter oder halbfertigprodukte
macht sich das jetzt schon unmittelbar
bemerkbar bei ihnen im hafen und wie
geht man vor allen dingen mit diesen
lieferungen um die ja schon längere zeit
unterwegs sind wird jetzt genau in den
container nachgesehen was da drin ist
wie wirksam kann man diese sanktionen
dann auch in ihrem bereich durchführen
ja also wir merken das schon sehr direkt
und lena die nicht mehr nach russland
verschifft werden
stehen zum teil auch im hafen und
blockieren auch die die terminals und
die plätze im hafen nicht nur in hamburg
und
was in den drin ist das sieht man
natürlich eine tolle erklärung sofern es
das relativ einfach zu erkennen im
moment ist es allerdings so dass die
meisten fast alle linien reedereien den
verkehr eingestellt haben und die
buchungen auch gestoppt haben insofern
ist die der warenfluss im prinzip dem
container gestoppt bei den massengütern
sie das noch etwas anders aus die kohle
wird noch weiter transportiert
dieselkraftstoff weiter transportiert
das ist noch nicht auf der
sanktionsliste
aber auch da merken wir schon dass die
kunden die hier
diese güter eingekauft haben bis dato
sich jetzt schon warum bemühen
alternativen zu finden das heißt also
eigentlich merken sie von den sanktionen
schon etwas von den maßnahmen das heißt
aber auch der empfänger russland müsste
dann ja auch bereits jetzt etwas merken
das ist also relativ schnell gegangen
also beim seeverkehr ist sehr schnell
gegangen
ihren stopps und die transporte sind
wirklich eingestellt wir haben natürlich
aber noch waren verkehr auf der schiene
das ist interessant wie sich das weiter
entwickeln wird wir haben natürlich auch
die ganze seitenstraßen verkehre wir
haben china china züge die durch
russland in richtung europa unterwegs
sind die laufen noch das ist
eingeschränkt durch die ukraine führt
natürlich gar nichts mehr
das wird sich auf jeden fall bemerkbar
machen schnell gibt es denn
wenn man diese aktion jetzt anziehen
wieder beschlossen worden sind gibt es
eigentlich noch mehr druckmittel hat man
da schon alle karten ausgespielt was
könnte man sich dann noch vorstellen um
putin dazu zu bringen von der ukraine zu
lassen ich weiß dass nicht ich glaube
nur dass diese vorstellung dass der
ökonomische druck wird erhöht und das
wird irgendwann zu einem einlenken
führen
das ist oder es wird zu einer rebellion
führen der gesteigerten unzufriedenheit
ich glaube dass diese wie soll ich sage
diese vorstellung von einem mechanischen
entwicklung überhaupt nicht
funktionieren der krieg ist ein so
enormes
neues ereignis das eingreift und zwar
nicht nur im ökonomischen termini dass
man in den supermarkt nicht mehr alles
das kriegt was man bekommen hat sondern
es gibt bilder die bilder von diesen
zerstörten städten wie kommen nach
russland irgendwie durch die sozialen
netzwerke durch die millionenfachen
familiären verbindungen die es ja gibt
diese bilder sicher nein es ist so dass
heute abend ist sind wiederum sender
geschlossen worden es gibt praktisch
überhaupt keine stimme mehr die
in der die denkenden leute
informieren könnten die wahrheit sagen
könnten die leute gehen außer landes das
heißt eine neue ökonomische betrachtung
funktioniert überhaupt nicht sondern es
gibt
dinge die plötzlich ein umschlag oder
jedenfalls sozusagen den herrn der
glaubt er ist der herr des verfahrens
vor eine ganz neue situation stellen
können wir wissen nicht was da ist ob es
jemanden gibt wo es eine gruppe gibt die
in der lage ist in sozusagen aus dem
verkehr zu ziehen das wissen die nicht
es gibt aber solche stimmen ja ich denke
nur an die an den brief der
offiziersgesellschaft von iwaschow vor
einigen wochen schon der gesagt hat also
ein patriotischer militär ein ehemaliger
general wie gesagt hat die politik von
putin ein krieg die die ein bruder volk
vom zaun zu brechen
das leben von tausenden von russischen
soldaten aufs spiel zu setzen dass das
ist gefährlich für unser land also für
russland wir müssen wir entgegentreten
und er war bestimmt nicht der einzige
das heißt in diesem szenario gibt es
nicht nur um ökonom die verschlimmerung
und verschlechterung des lebensstandards
sondern krieg ist ein ganz neues moment
was ins leben hinein kommt und was die
eu keine angeht ich habe heute einen
bericht gelesen dass durch diese
kriegshandlungen sind weite teile der
ukraine und es ist ja die sogenannte
kornkammer
europas und der welt sind durch die
kriegshandlungen ist die aussaat also
für dieses jahr in gefahr was bedeutet
das eigentlich für den weltmarkt
bedeutet es dass die preise steigen und
so weiter für für getreide aber in
wirklichkeit ist es eine auslieferung
der ukraine was ihre sozusagen als
agrarland sie haben in diesem jahr keine
ernte wenn nicht ausgesät werden kann
dann hat man auch keine ernte und das
sind verwüstungen die nicht einfach
durch ökonomische mechanismen erklärt
oder neutralisiert werden können sondern
das sind einschneidende
gravierende dinge die auch etwas in den
köpfen in bewegung setzen und das heißt
nicht dass man jetzt hoffen muss dass
oder erwarten kann dass 1000 jetzt auf
die straßen denn obwohl es bemerkenswert
ist die ungeheure breite diesmal der
wortmeldungen also es sind nicht nur
proteste in petersburg in moskau sondern
in den sogenannten provinz städten es
gab erklärungen von allen berufszweigen
ob das journalisten ärzte lehrer
mitglieder der akademie der
wissenschaften waren also ist es ein
ziemlich eine ziemlich breite
angelegenheit und ich finde dass die
ukrainische regierung eine sehr gute und
offensive politik macht indem sie die
fotos der gefangenen soldaten
veröffentlicht eine eine website
eröffnet hat wo die mütter die gar nicht
wissen was mit ihren söhnen los ist sich
melden können und das funktioniert auch
das heißt es geht hier nicht nur um
ökonomie und sanktionen sondern
das sind mehr dinge im spiel die wir im
auge behalten müssen inklusive der
militärischen mit putin geht es weiter
in diese richtung frau fischer die
ukraine ist ja eine der kammern dieser
welt ist ja ein wichtiger weizen und
mais exporte möglicherweise fällt diese
ernte aus und nicht nur das die ukraine
der ukraine droht möglicherweise eine
hungersnot je nachdem wie groß die
zerstörungen sind das ist ja eine der
wichtigsten aufgaben von pooth für die
welt auch da dann in aktion zu treten
haben gibt es da schon planungen bei
ihnen für diesen fall
naja also was ist im moment gibt es auf
jeden fall jede menge also vorbereitung
für unterstützung
das macht unsere schwester organisation
die diakonie katastrophenhilfe
und moment ist es so dass die kollegen
auch fieberhaft bei brot für die welt
einfach versuchen erstmal raus zu
bekommen wie sich also sozusagen
hochrechnungen auch zu machen und
überhaupt erstmal zu analysieren wie die
situation
in dem bereich der ernährungssicherung
ausfällt da kann ich ihnen im moment
aber jetzt noch meine wirklichen
ergebnisse sagen das ist ein ziemlich
kompliziertes
bereich und da gibt es auch also da ist
es einfach wichtig gute an der lösung zu
machen und dann sind wir dran da können
wir vielleicht ein paar tagen jetzt hier
mehr zu sagen gut also das heißt nicht
nur die kriegerischen handlungen mit den
fatalen folgen für die menschen sondern
eben auch das was in den nächsten
monaten da drohen könnte also was ja was
uns beschäftigt ist vor allen dingen
natürlich auch die auswirkungen dieser
ganze krise mit dem getreide mangel dann
oder diesen mangelnden ernten auf dem
globalen süden
ich habe viele länder die auch mit der
ukraine und auch mit russland einfach
dort
handelsbeziehungen haben und dann
wiederum die leidtragenden sind also das
betrifft aber nicht nur die ukraine
sondern auch also afrikanischen
peer kluge was wären denn wenn wir noch
mal auf die sanktionen schauen
eigentlich da sind die wirksame
sanktionen im moment gegen gegen
russland also wie gesagt im öl und
gasbereich finden ja keine stadt die
werden wahrscheinlich die wirksamsten
aber das würde ja erst recht auf uns
dann möglicherweise zurückfallen sind
das die das abklemmen von den
finanzmärkten sind dass diese produkte
wie ein high tech
it-strukturen computer vor allen dingen
aber
ersatzteile für flugzeuge denn susan ist
ein riesiges land besonders abhängig von
einem funktionierenden flugverkehr ein
drei viertel aller russischen flugzeuge
sind im westen geleast kann man damit
russland richtig
richtig kriegen naja die geleasten
flugzeuge sind wahrscheinlich weg also
das ist zumindest der stand heute dass
die wahrscheinlich von ostern enteignet
werden oder ist russland das zumindest
versuchen wird aber zu den maßnahmen
es gibt konkrete maßnahmen wo man sagen
kann das ist die dass es die härtesten
sind das sind die sogenannten blocking
sessions der vereinigten staaten gegen
russische banken die sorgen dafür dass
die banken komplett aus dem
international wirtschaftsleben
abgeschnitten werden banken sind so
etwas wie das nervensystem dass der
volkswirtschaft das heißt wenn man da
ein stück rausreißt dann hat das
auswirkungen massive auswirkung auf
alles andere und die zweite komponente
sind die banken gegen die aktionen gegen
die russische zentralbank das sorgt
dafür dass russland praktisch die hände
gebunden sind und die regierung weniger
stark gegensteuern kann das sind
sozusagen bei den maßnahmen die
wirkungsweise aber ich muss hier gleich
sagen aktuell geht es gar nicht um die
einzelmaßnahmen aktuelle situation in
der alle unternehmen die mit russland
geschäfte machen nicht wissen ob eine
lieferung die sie heute losschicken in
zwei wochen überhaupt noch ankommen darf
ankommen kann bezahlt werden kann
das heißt es gibt eine extreme
unsicherheit und das führt dazu dass
aktuell gar keine geschäfte mehr gemacht
werden obwohl sie noch legal wären das
heißt die sanktionen sind das eine aber
die erwartungen der marktakteure gehen
weit darüber hinaus es gibt da eine
strafende strafen der reaktion der
märkte die dazu geführt hat dass eben
jetzt in russland tatsächlich auch ganz
ganz vieles was vielleicht theoretisch
auch in sanktions folge noch erlaubt
wird nicht mehr passiert sowieso eine
art ökonomische streumunition die noch
ganz andere wirkungen und zwar ziemlich
schnelle wirkungen hat die wirkung von
sanktionen ist der komplex und
tatsächlich hat es jetzt eine sehr
schnelle wirkung wenn eben diese
unsicherheit die aktuell herrscht
erhalten bleibt wenn es jetzt eine
situation gäbe es war 2014 nach
sanktionen auch so wo das ganze sich
nach einigen monaten oder jahren ein
spielt dann verliert sich diese wirkung
aber aktuell ist wirklich herrscht das
chaos in russland in der wirtschaft und
das ist sozusagen der stärkste sie haben
ja gerade gesagt das sei auch ein kampf
und putin gegen die eigene elite die er
eigentlich bräuchte in diesem staat um
sich durchzusetzen stichwort die
oligarchen distanzieren sich jetzt
einige haben auch angst um ihre pfründe
versuchen in aller größen und ihre
teuren millionen yachten in sicherheit
zu bringen und und und abend überhaupt
noch einfluss auf ihren mann hat ja auch
informationen dass er dass die meisten
oligarchen ihm ja viel verdanken gar
nicht mehr an ihn ran kommen er braucht
die rolle gleichen nicht und die alten
haben keinen einfluss mehr haben schon
seit längerer zeit keinen einfluss mehr
die mächtigsten wirtschaftsakteuren
ostern sind auch gleichzeitig akteure
aus den sicherheitsorganen dh das hat
sich völlig geändert die die oligarchen
verlieren jetzt alles aktuell die hatten
sehr sehr viel und auch in
internationale vernetzung investiert und
diese unternehmen werden jetzt praktisch
ja vielleicht nicht wertlos aber sie
werden praktisch gar nicht mehr
existieren wie sie vorerst der
sicherheits aber 30 jetzt quasi die
russischen das ist schon projekte der
vergangenheit aber das war ein teil des
systems routine und das eben die
unabhängige oligarchen stück für stück
verdrängt wurden und menschen aus dem
persönlichen umfeld von putin um
menschen aus den sicherheitsorganen eben
immer mächtiger geworden sind immer mehr
einfluss bekommen haben über die großen
konzerne
hermann was so über die häfen rein und
kommt oder raus geht also der seehandel
ist ja eigentlich das rückgrat der
weltwirtschaft gerade auch wichtig für
ein land wie deutschland das ja sehr
stark von exporten abhängig ist das ist
ja ein barometer was gerade passiert und
was demnächst passieren könnte sind wir
bei der abteilung kosten der freiheit
angelangt dass wir eben jetzt sanktionen
lassen die aber auf uns möglicherweise
zurückgefallen aber diese sanktionen
wollen wir erlassen und um unsere
unabhängigkeit unsere freiheit zu
sichern was glauben sie denn worauf sich
wenn sie jetzt auch selbst den
warenverkehr gerade im bereich ansehen
worauf sich die deutsche wirtschaft da
demnächst einstellen muss welche großen
verluste wird das geben muss eine
rezession
befürchtet werden
auf jeden fall muss sich die deutsche
wirtschaft und die weltwirtschaft auf
große flexibilität einstellen also wir
haben unzählige
handelsbeziehungen zwischen firmen in
europa und in russland und die sind
natürlich jetzt gestört und oder sind
völlig ausgeschaltet aber wir haben
natürlich auch eine sehr flexible
wirtschaft und wir haben auch gerade in
der logistik in der wohnung als häfen
tätig sind die logistik ist sehr
flexibel also es wird natürlich dann
alternativen auch geben für den einkauf
von waren auch wenn wir uns die kohle
anschauen oder oder andere sachen dann
ist es so dass das natürlich auf dem
weltmarkt auch noch andere möglichkeiten
gibt das heißt dass es teurer wird das
heißt dass es komplizierter wird und
wahrscheinlich auch etwas dauert aber
grundsätzlich sind alternativen dar aber
wir werden natürlich
eine eine große
verwirrung sehen und die haben wir jetzt
schon weil natürlich in vielen bereichen
die man die man noch gar nicht beziffern
kann die handelsbeziehungen unterbrochen
sind und daran hängen ja dann auch noch
mal wieder andere beziehungen und es
gibt zulieferbetriebe das gibt halt
fertigteile die transportiert werden
müssen oder eben jetzt nicht mehr
transportiert werden also da ist eine
vielfältige verbindungen
vielfältige verknüpfungen zwischen
unternehmen in russland und in europa
und in der welt die jetzt durch diese
sanktionen unterbrochen ihr habt werden
diese handelswege regelrecht demoliert
bis jetzt war es ja in der pandemie so
dass der seehandel gelitten hat die
sogenannten lieferketten waren zum teil
unterbrochen dass sie in einer der
restriktiven politik chinas vor allem
zusammenhang mit corona dann hat sich
wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden
haben den unterlagen ja der
handelsverkehr dann auf die neue seiten
straße verlegt sie haben schon gesagt
also bahnverbindungen von china nach
europa der hat auch gewaltig zugenommen
er ist jetzt wahrscheinlich auf lange
zeit unterbrochen durch die durch den
krieg und durch den konflikt mit
russland der
frachtverkehr in der luft kann das
wahrscheinlich ausgleichen kommt da
gerade auf den internationalen handel
wirklich kommt da wirklich sehr schwere
zeiten zu
da wir müssen uns die menge nur
anschauen also die mengen die auf der
seidenstraße auf den zügen zwischen
china und europa transportiert werden
die sind überschaubar im vergleich zu
dem was wir die maritime seidenstraße
also den seeverkehr transportiert wird
sicherlich wird das jetzt weniger werden
wir sehen jetzt schon buchungsrückgänge
also die züge fahren zwar noch aber die
kunden buchen nicht mehr auf diesen
verbindung im moment ist es allerdings
so dass man sie auch gerade erwähnt dass
die sogenannte weltweite supply chain
sowieso schon sehr angestrengt ist und
es wird nicht so sein dass die mengen
die bis dato über die zügel gegangen
sind eins zu eins wird seeschiffen
transportiert werden können die
kapazitäten dafür sind nicht vorhanden
und da wird es interessant wie welche
wege sich da an war es schön dass
glauben sie wielange halten wir das
durch mit
auf und bezogen diese sanktionen die
solidarität der wirtschaft die sich ja
jetzt zeigt dass man auch ohne
politische vorgaben fast alle
beziehungen zu russland abgebrochen hat
dass wir möglicherweise auch eine menge
materieller opfer finanziell oft
verbringen müssen das umfeld ja auf uns
zurück das wird uns auch in
mitleidenschaft ziehen was denken sie
wird dass solches gefühl man muss der
ukraine hilfen bei diesen bildern an die
man sich vielleicht auch gewöhnen kann
glauben sie dass das anhält
ich glaube dass die der aufbruch und die
augen aufzumachen auf das was da
passiert dass das in den letzten
tagen und wochen offensichtlich geworden
ist also wenn ich mir die bilder von der
kundgebung am wochenende gestern in
münchen an sie ja das ist ausdruck einer
überwältigen und bewegtheit der menschen
für das was dort passiert ich wollte
aber noch sagen also wir können alles
mögliche was in den nächsten jahrzehnten
oder jahren passieren soll wir müssen
uns gefasst machen darauf dass jeden tag
etwas anderes passieren kann was alle
diese planungen die auch mit sanktionen
verbunden sind einfach über den haufen
wirft heute abend gab es bilder von den
rauchfahnen über dem kraftwerk von
saccharose
saccharose ist eines der größten
atomkraftwerke
tschernobyl ist sozusagen in die
kriegshandlungen einbezogen gewesen
oder wenn wir schon von handel und von
den häfen sprechen mariupol und odessa
sind beschossen und was mit odessa
passiert in den nächsten tagen wir
wissen es nicht und wir müssen uns auf
dinge wir müssen gefasst sein dass etwas
passiert und es sind schon dinge
passiert in den bars in den kämpfen sind
chemische katastrophen von denen man
überhaupt nicht mehr gesprochen hat
ganze gruppen anlagen stehen unter
wasser ganze landstriche sind radioaktiv
verseucht was passiert eigentlich wenn
die kampfhandlungen um saccharose
weitergehen was was tun die europäer
dann und meine frage wäre eben nicht nur
immer zu gucken auf atomkrieg und diese
diese entweder oder sondern was kann man
eigentlich tun um diese so zeige
katastrophen die sich im zusammenhang
mit kampfhandlungen entwickeln können
abzuwehren und ich fand dass die leute
die heute auf der straße waren mit
freude ist auf youtube future die haben
irgendwie eine vorstellung gehabt was
dort auch sozial ökologisches was dort
an ökologischen katastrophen passieren
könnte zu ihrer frage ich glaube die
prüfung ob wir standhalten und wir auch
bereit sind etwas sozusagen für die
ukraine aber die ukraine halten ja im
grunde im augenblick nur den kopf hin ja
und ihren körper hin für uns alle das
wird sich das wird sich zeigen
und man hat jetzt sozusagen in aller
munde dieses monumentale wort von der
zeitenwende ja hinter dieser zeitenwende
was ja stimmt aber wir werden sehen ja
ob wir uns ob wir das durchhalten und
putins kalkül ist natürlich dass diese
westen so egoistisch so an seinem leben
wie es weitergehen soll interessiert ist
dass wir diesen opfern und diesen
prüfungen nicht standhält in seinen
augen ist europa ein dekadenter
kontinent der duh nur darauf wartet
gerettet zu werden von ihnen den starken
mann jetzt geht es um die frage wie geht
es weiter fischer sie haben vorhin ja
schon von möglichen vermittlungen
gesprochen selbst wenn man jetzt sich
kaum vorstellen kann dass es
verhandlungen zum beispiel auf höchster
ebene gibt aber es gibt ja vielleicht
vermittlungsbemühungen die gibt es ja
sogar im moment zwischen ukrainern und
rüsten obwohl sie ziemlich erfolglos in
china hat hier schon eine rolle gespielt
im zusammenhang auch mit der
wirtschaftlichen entwicklung als sie es
für denkbar dass vielleicht aus dieser
richtung auch aus wirtschaftlichem
eigeninteresse an eine initiative kommt
da in der ukraine vermittelt zu wollen
zumindest sollte man nichts unversucht
lassen auch diplomatische bemühungen mit
china aufzunehmen und auch mit indien
zum beispiel und zu versuchen diese
länder mit einzubeziehen und irgendwie
dafür zu gewinnen denn ich denke wenn
präsident putin noch auf irgendjemanden
hört dann vielleicht auf den
chinesischen
führer also da das sollte man zumindest
einkalkulieren als möglichkeit und ich
habe ja vorhin gesagt es geht um eine
sprech kanäle auf allen ebenen als es
nicht so dass ich jetzt also wirklich
die große hoffnung auf ein bestimmtes
treffen richtet das ist ja ein prozess
das kann ja über längere zeiträume auch
gehen und das was glaube ich auch nicht
von da an zu reißen ist es gab ja vor
einiger zeit vorschläge von ehemaligen
soldaten
ehemaligen diplomaten und eine reihe von
wissenschaftlern die gesagt haben wir
brauchen eigentlich wirklich so eine
mehrjährige konferenz auch auf
europäischer ebene wo wir über eine neue
und eine andere europäische
sicherheitsarchitektur sprechen und
dieses dieser vorschlag ist damals nicht
erhört worden jetzt schon einige zeit
her aber ich finde es weiterhin
notwendig weil man auch diese potenziale
dieser organisation für sicherheit und
zusammenarbeit in europa nutzen muss das
ist eine organisation in der eben 57
staaten doch
zusammengewirkt haben in der
vergangenheit und wo es instrumente
rüstungskontrolle und
vertrauensbildende maßnahmen und die
sollte man nicht ganz aufgeben sondern
wiederbeleben so ist das im moment noch
nicht zu finden auch langfristig dass
wir eine solche neue europäische
sicherheitsarchitektur
hinbekommen die darf natürlich weder von
vom russischen präsidenten diktiert
werden aber sie sollte auch nicht von
den usa dominiert werden also das los
irgend was neu ist und was anderes her
und vertrauensbildende maßnahmen sind
einfach wichtig auch wenn das im moment
absurd klingen mag weil putin jedes
vertrauen verspielt hat aber wir müssen
auch diese ebene weitermachen darf ich
ganz wie gesagt
wir sind gleich am ende der sendung
die wirtschaft wird also möglicherweise
massiven schaden erleiden herr kluge
könnte es sein dass sie auch ähnliche
bei corona balkone pandemie
schadensersatz vom von der politik
fordert die ja diese sanktionen erlassen
hat dann würde ich gerne gleich muss
aber trotzdem mal klar ständig ich
glaube jetzt nicht aktuell dass wir
zusätzliche vermittlung brauchen wie
wollen sie vermitteln mit jemanden der
einen vernichtungskrieg gegen eine
benachbarte demokratie führt wie möchten
sie eine sicherheitsarchitektur
errichten mit jemandem der einen krieg
gegen die zivilbevölkerung
die langen gesicht war ja auch gesagt
wurden sicherlich aber das kann nicht
putin sein es kann solange putin an der
macht das ist europäische sicherheit
abgrenzung und verteidigung gegen putin
ich glaube da müssen wir uns ganz im
klaren darüber sein dürfen keine
illusionen haben dass er mit diesem mann
gemeinsam eine sicherheitsarchitektur in
europa aufbauen können das wird mehr
arbeiten an den zu ihrer garage ein
bisschen wenn der kurzen antwort ist
wenngleich am ende ok
letztlich wenn jemand in rosa investiert
ist ein risikoreiches land das heißt die
kapitaleigner müssten eigentlich nicht
entschädigt werden weil risiko auch
eingepreist werden muss es gibt da
haftung wenn arbeitnehmer davon
betroffen sind die praktisch da
unschuldiger weise mit reingezogen
werden müsste der staat an der stelle
auch schadenersatz leisten würden sie
damit ziehen bei dieser haltung
auf jeden fall so dass er gesagt hat das
auch so betragen dann bedanke ich mich
für das gespräch wir sind am ende der
sendung das thema wird uns noch lange
beschäftigen rund um die ukraine
ausfielen die kriegen den heraus ich
betrachte er bedanke mich bei karl
schlögel bei janis kluge bei martina
fischer und bei axel mattern liebe
zuschauer jetzt folgt phoenix der tag
mit dem thema wie gesagt dass uns noch
lange beschäftigt ukraine alles was
heute passiert ist mit konstanzer pracki
bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]